[Music]
welcome to earbiscus the podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time i'm linked and i'm rhett
this week at the round table of dim
lighting
we are talking about our top 12
creative influences we usually now we've
done top 10 episodes where it's like top
10 favorite films or top 10 favorite
whatever we do
television shows we wanted we've had
this one on the list of things to do for
a while
but i think we've both been a little bit
intimidated and the process by which i
kind of got into this only
confirmed my intimidation so much so
that literally
yeah 10 minutes ago i was like dude we
got to make this 12 because
i just feel like i'm selling people
short i feel i don't know how i feel
about the 12 i don't know how i feel
about the order i just yeah i feel well
you know almost creatively crippled
right now you know what hey
let's take a deep breath and let's just
let's shed that
this is just a construct for us to have
a conversation about
this is good the people that we believe
in the right have
they've
they've entered our psyche they've
become part they've impacted us to
various degrees
that then it has
made its way into the
it's permeated us to then come out in
our own creativity and
yeah it's it's quite an exercise to
connect those dots but
let's just say
these are not definitive lists
let's also say
that
i know that i forgot people oh yeah and
none of them are listening and part of
that's gonna probably come when you've
got somebody on your list and i'm like
oh hopefully yeah we don't like we don't
know each other's i got 15 honorable
mentions that i'll mention at the end we
have not just in case we've seen
each other's lists we're going to
alternate starting with 12.
i'll go with twitter
and we're going to do the traditional
method which is uh because i'm assuming
there's some crossover that if a person
says my number 12 is
blankety blank and that per and then the
other guy's like my number two is
blankety blank
higher goes first in talking about it oh
the person who ranks higher ranks that
person higher gets to talk about them
first
but they have to talk about them earlier
than they were ready to right which so
it's a little bit of a compromise so
yeah you have to do something you don't
want to do
and i i'll say that
more so than other lists and it's always
been tough
that the actual
ranking
is much more arbitrary the ranking could
be upside down even as far as
really all the way to the top because
yeah yeah how do you measure these
it's how you evaluate it which we can
get into i think we'll get into those
specifics as we roll these people out
yeah
there's a difference between
inspiration
and
influence
too right and so depending on the person
sometimes there's a direct connection
with something that i experienced or
learned
from a person that then directly
impacted something from our career
other times it's just kind of the
the idea of their approach or the way
that it made me feel or it's it's much
more
nebulous in general so it's kind of all
over the place
um well last thing i'll say that's true
of creativity yeah well last thing i'll
say before we break into the list
is that this is not an uncommon question
in interviews like who are your biggest
creative influences and i think that
we've always had this or i feel like
i've had this i don't speak for you i've
had this sense that like
i don't like you know i'm not formally
trained in anything i went to harnett
county public schools i didn't do
anything creative in training i went to
engineering school i always get this
weird feeling and super high imposter
syndrome when you start talking about
creative influences because i don't have
a creative background i've just lived
and breathed creativity
my entire life and so i don't know what
to say in those situations but when i
really dug down and started going back
to the beginning of like when did you
start thinking about creative things
i started realizing that
there's a lot of people who have been
having fun
and i don't want to say like oh i don't
have influences i'm just saying that i
get intimidated by the question yeah and
then even when we said we were going to
do 10 i was i was saying maybe we should
do five and now i've talked you into
doing 12 and i've got 15 honorable
mentions it's just this is a this is a
weird process
i'm excited to talk about it i do not
want you to mention your honorable
mentions because they may be on my list
no no no not
if you say somebody who's on my
honorable mentions only at that i'm only
at that point i'll be like ah they made
my honorable mention i'm not gonna say
that until the to the end whenever i
would get that question of creative
influences
because it's so hard to nail it down and
without a prepared answer or doing the
exercise that we've only started to do
for this episode
i would fall back on
i don't you know i'm not a student of a
lot of the things we do a lot of what we
do is kind of like we were among the
group of people that invented it
honestly yeah so
there hasn't been there hasn't been
people in like the the world have
created them if you could call it to
emulate that went ahead of us right
because it didn't exist ahead of us so
if you look at it that way and i always
thought of that as an asset
it's like okay this sets us up to be
more original and more ourselves and
people can emulate us if they want to
but really it was
i think part of it was just
being intimidated by the work
that we started to do who wants to start
you want to start you with number 12
sure um
i'm going to start i put this person at
number 12
because i felt like putting them in any
number
was weird and it's they either had to be
at number 12 or number one and i put
them in number 12 because it you like to
understand my dad okay so i just started
with jimmy my dad as a creative
personality now i've said this quite a
bit about how i totally get it my
sense of humor is largely informed by
the way my dad's your sense of humor is
and the things that he thinks are funny
in the way that he interjects himself
into a conversation the way that he
once he sort of has an audience the way
that he would
uh begin to entertain that audience i've
said forever that if i wasn't a comedian
i would be a professor well that's what
my dad was for his entire life basically
starting in like 1980. so he had an
audience he had an audience every single
day my observation
because i definitely think he's also
a comedic influence on me like i can
even to this day if there's a you'll
make a joke and i'll be like that's a
jimmy joke oh yeah um and it's like if
it's if it's dry and a little
i want
let's see how do you describe it it's
it's dry like not derogatory or judgy
but it's it's observational
and it might
sometimes it might be kind of like in in
good spirits making fun of something or
somebody
uh there's a bit of that and there's a
confidence in it there's a kind of
confidence in the swagger and then his
and his humor he was good in in small
groups
like i mean a classroom is an awkward
size if you're
like i've never been a stand-up comedian
but if you are
it's like when you when you're speaking
to a big room or an arena even when you
go bigger it's a different thing but
when a room gets too small
it's like you're talking to people in
like a doctor's
waiting room it's like that's in that's
intimidating
like for us to to be behind the desk on
gmm and know that there's a million
people watching
every day
you just kind of get over it first of
all they're not there
there's just a lens
but second of all
that's different than even my experience
now if i'm in like a
a
like a hangout
and like you're telling a story and then
all of a sudden it's just like that
the eight people are listening to your
story that's a different vibe it kind of
puts you in a different spot
but your dad is good in those situations
he is good but i think the thing that
i've really taken from him is that
because i'm also not i'm not very
comfortable in those sort of media small
and medium sized groups now i can't i
can be and i can go into my but i have
to kind of shift from get some mindset
personal rat to entertainer right yeah
um because a lot of people might think
oh i bet you when rhett link are hanging
out with their friends they're just
funny funny funny
it's not true it's just not true it
partly because
it's
a profession in some sense yeah but
there's also a power dynamic that comes
with
being recognized as the person who's
currently has the power to speak to a
crowd so a professor has that a comedian
has that they have the microphone yeah
um i tend to that's where i'm at my best
is when i have the power yeah
that makes
you know i'm not not in a negative sense
but when it's just like all right monkey
dance
that's when i that's when i do well but
if it's just like everybody's just kind
of being personal and personal in this
situation and now are you going to say
something funny you're right my dad is
really good at that he's good with the
quips he's not he wasn't as much of a
storyteller or there's all types of
genres he does he has some really funny
stories we've got some funny stories
well
i haven't
heard as much of those it's more of like
the one-liners someone else is talking
and then he'll lean over and say
something to you like give you a little
private commentary and he also has
things like if you're like i remember i
don't remember exactly what he said but
i'll paraphrase
like getting on an elevator at an at a
like a tourist attraction like okay 15
people get on an elevator to go to the
top of the empire state building or
whatever right and so you're with a
bunch of strangers and everybody's no
one talks right
so like one minute into an elevator ride
my dad will be like so how's everybody
doing today you know it's like he'll
he'll do something to break the ice when
he senses that there's
an awkward situation but he's not one of
those
some people may do that because they're
friendly and they're outgoing he's doing
it because the choice to do it is funny
oh yeah definitely
but he is friendly and outgoing but
that's not like the main reason he's
doing it is because doing this now
is funny so
as i think about just
obviously genetic influences but also
environmental influences in the way that
i and the things that i think are funny
is so largely influenced by him
genetically and the way that he behaved
growing up that i got to put him on the
list and it probably makes sense for him
to be
number one since like fifty percent of
my dna but it's like i just put him on
the list he's just
influenced you in a lot of ways
like the comedy it was just it's it
sprinkles in and it comes out
occasionally
like
if you say the if one of us is gonna be
the one to make the dry quip
it's absolutely gonna be you and you can
trace that to your dad
the one liner and the like your dad
didn't raise an eyebrow but it he kind
it it was that same effect
yeah
uh my number 12
i i'm hoping to surprise you with this
one with a oh yes
because that's how i felt when i
actually thought of this one
ross mcelwee
ross mcelwee oh you put him on your list
number five are you oh man
i thought you would have forgotten him
entirely
not only is ross mcelwee my number five
i've gotten but my wreck today comes
from ross mcelwee okay um well let me
help you out with um just kind of giving
some background on the guy um he's a
documentary filmmaker from the 80s
and on
he
he was
first famous for sherman's march the
longer
title is sherman's march a meditation on
the possibility of romantic love in the
south during an era of nuclear weapons
proliferation you're really stealing my
thunder that's my wreck man well we're
talk i have to give him context for who
this guy is
um
[Music]
he also released uh an autobiographical
documentary in 1993 called time
indefinite
but
so i'll let you why did you put him so
high because yeah i could have put him
there too
set the scene
when we watched that that first film
sherman's march
i remember
thinking
well where were we do you remember that
when in our
life we were watching it
it was like right after college it was
i i'm pretty sure it was with in context
of starting
to make our own documentary looking from
his locklear
i think it was the thing that led us to
do it definitely i don't think i don't
think we made the decision to do it
back to it well so because we were
getting into documentaries the thing
that the thing that we like so much that
that i really connected with so much
about this guy
is that he
made documentaries that were incredibly
uh vulnerable personally vulnerable they
were really extra a personal exercise in
uh it was self-exploration and
self-discovery through the lens of other
people right and so he was in his he was
the main character in his documentary i
call self-insertion
self-insertion documentary which is not
a great term
which again is exactly what we did with
looking for miss locklear way back in
the day yeah i also think super size me
yeah the thing that
i love so much about it
is i'm really drawn towards documentary
film where the thing that's on display
is the people first
not
um
a subject or an agenda or a cause now i
like like political documentaries i like
documentaries that all of a sudden
change the way that you think about the
environment i like those humanity on
display i totally agree but it's about
the people
and that's why no i didn't put errol
morris on errol morris on my list he was
an honorable mention for i love errol
morris for the same exact reason but
ross mcelwee is the one that we first
connected with and then the way well
he's from north carolina he was it was
so related there was another film bright
leaves which is about his connection to
like the to his family's connection to
the tobacco industry in north carolina
so we had this
connection
and we definitely were referring to it
and were actively
inspired by what he did in 1986 and on
when we were in 2003 making looking for
miss locklear and not just looking for
miss locklear but i would say the entire
commercial kings series
all of our i love local commercials it
was based on that same principle if we
just love people and we love people
who've never been on camera or not
prepared to be on camera
and
actually one of the the things that i am
most sort of creatively restless about
over the past
10 years has been the fact that we
haven't been able to get back to that
yeah i'll go one step further than just
commercial kings and say
again we were making it was 2003 when we
were we were filming looking for miss
locklear didn't come out until 2006 yeah
so this is like pre-youtube
pre-vlogging
really taking taking hold in in any
meaningful way so the fact that he was
autobiographical
vulnerable it was it was
it was putting his story out there but
he was the guy controlling the camera he
would set the camera down then he would
walk out and he would be in front of it
and he would there would be different
scenes that he would set up we emulated
that directly and looking for mr
but this is a it's a vlog precursor
you know in a lot of ways uh and it was
so it was more artistic and even though
we never
i mean we were very late and hesitant to
vlogging we had this seed planted from
this era in our creativity
that
gave us an appetite to connect directly
with our audience and not just create
things
for an audience to enjoy separate from
us yeah so i i
that's why i think he's so important
but not i mean not as important as i
thought he was so yeah again it was he
hits i just put him on i had to put him
somewhere all right what's your 11 um
[Music]
my 11 is maybe this will surprise you
c.s lewis
okay uh so i get it
for use
i'll keep this one relatively short so
c.s lewis of course
you know famously no he was he's
famously known as like a christian
theologian and an author
but the thing that i really connected
with him about was the chronicles of
narnia which not a huge fan of the
movies let me just say that um i'm
definitely a lord of the rings guy when
it comes to the movies
and ultimately in adulthood the books of
lord of the rings but it's crazy that
they were like really contemporary yeah
jrr tolkien i've been to the bar where
they i've been to the bar next to oxford
where they hang out you told me uh so
the thing about c.s lewis is the first
fantasy literature that i've ever ever
read and it's so approachable it's so
easy to read it as like a
eight nine ten year old
and i consumed the chronicles of narnia
voraciously at like the age of ten
and just fell in love with these stories
i mean you can re i mean it was your
harry potter you can really wasn't a
harry potter and you can also read them
in like a couple of nights there's so
much they're so much shorter
and
the the thing that i love about the
chronicles of narnia is
it starts in the real world and this is
true of much fantasy but it starts in
the real world and then there is a
wardrobe that gets you into a fantasy
world and that is a concept that i've
never been it just it's like it went
into my soul and connected with me on
this cosmic level
and i am so intrigued by any story that
follows this convention
we're starting in the real world and
there is a pathway to another place any
movie that does that and does it well
i'm all in the whole time right it's one
of the reasons that i don't think that
my soul can i don't know why the first
thing i thought about was being john
malkovich but go ahead but it's also i
like secret rooms and uh it's the reason
that we put that weird locker in the
first season a buddy system is like oh
what if we opened a locker in that a
secret bag in there you know i love that
convention and love to put it in things
but also um
our novel the lost cause is a bleak
creek yeah i mean you go same thing yeah
you've absolutely got that in the creek
and so that
way of thinking about the world
and way of thinking about
take taking
what taking what is possible
or taking what is impossible and
bringing it into the possible sort of
tangible world is something that
it permeates the way that i think about
story and that comes from cs lewis i
mean that was the first it was in me
already right
but he's the one who brought it out and
it was like oh there's a whole world
there's a whole life there's there's all
these possibilities that exist
in this world that you can get through
and
as a kid
many times
i would be walking through the woods and
i would see like a tree that had like a
hole in it and i would be like
okay
is that my narnia
and i would pray
god
if this is narnia
let me in like you know i wanted to be
in it so bad pray to god yeah well i
mean because you know that was my way of
thinking
aslan
and so
cs lewis i don't there's not i don't
want to say anything else because we got
a lot to get through my number 11 i'm
can i surprise you with this one
robert rodriguez okay he was on the list
and i knocked him off okay he's an
honorable mention
that was tough that was tough uh robert
rodriguez uh
film director
producer um
early films
our desperado
antonio banderas
and selma hayek
really good movie
super cool
uh from dusk till dawn spy kids sin city
i mean he's even
i i hesitate to mention he directed many
episodes of the book of boba fett
uh one episode of uh
the mandalorian because of his like
his robert rodriguez take on like the
western gunslinger vibe
made him a great choice for that even
though he's getting a lot of backlash
for
the book of boba fett being kind of
tepid uh i'm not gonna go there but back
in 1992
his first film
called el mariachi yeah was uh
just a homemade
um
western
but like a gangster western like a guy
was carrying a guitar case
with uh
am i getting this confused with
desperado he had a guitar case
that then he opened it up and it had
this uh
it had uh
a gun in it
i it's been a long time since i've seen
it
but
we discovered him in the context of
quentin tarantino
um
who maybe is on your list but i actually
replaced
tarantino with robert rodriguez on my
list because
he wrote a book in 1995
which we read rebel without a crew with
rebel without a crew um
and
he basically chronicled making el
mariachi i mean it has this really
homemade feel to it
and but he shot it on film and he like
did it all himself he did not have a
crew and like he didn't even have actors
he had these
friends and
like acquaintances and pulling favors to
like make this epic
super
super cool vibe
um
violent movie
that you could tell he made it himself
but
the con
the conception and the creativity
involved in it just
it it overrode the homemade nature of it
and like you could definitely tell this
guy was a tremendous talent yeah and and
given the landscape of entertainment at
the time
i believe he you know he got a lot of
attention if not won awards at sundance
i don't know the d yeah that book was
transformational for us again he was on
the list and i yeah and again it was
like 1995 1996 like we're we're in high
school we're like talking about
going to film school i didn't read it
when it came out
i i i remember you don't think we read
in high school i read that i remember
reading that after college after college
that's when i read it so you may have
read it earlier i read it i just
remember reading that book and thinking
get it first of all we've always been
like
if we've got an idea we're going to find
a way to make it happen and when you you
connect with people who think the same
way and we always felt like outside we
scrapped everything together you know we
weren't like living in hollywood we
weren't doing the traditional thing of
like becoming a pa and working your way
up and then being the director one day
we were just a couple of guys in north
carolina and you see this guy who's
writing about
just do it
just make it if you want to make it
happen make it happen and there's a
couple of principles on that book that
really stuck with me the one that we
repeat time and time again
is whenever you're working on a project
and a film is the most applicable one
but
after you get the footage cut the
trailer first oh yeah that's where we
got that uh you know once you've you've
cut the footage or once you've gathered
the footage cut the trailer first
because the trailer gives you this
vision that you can look forward to you
you create a trailer that has the vibe
that you want the film to have
and it gives you this
you know true north to look at it
because you're going to make it real
especially if you're doing it all on
your own i mean this dude was scoring
his own films as well
you know he's stu he was literally doing
the score to everything back in the day
yeah
um so yeah we did that for looking for
miss locklear and then you you also can
show that trailer to people and they get
excited and it helps you to get
financing keep going yeah uh so yeah
there was a there was a lot to learn
there
uh from that from that book it took a
lot of inspiration but it was
you know once we were making our
documentary we we were filmmakers
we were filmmakers we entered it in film
festivals we won some awards
um that's shown on pbs man got shown on
pbs in in south carolina
hey i'll take it i'll take the
underbelly of north carolina
um yeah but we
we could put we could apply that label
to ourselves
and we could say we've done it we're
doing it this is yeah i mean we were on
staff with campus crusades still at the
time we were also that
but
it's like hey we have a film
so we are filmmakers we're we are
achieving the dream and it was and he
gave us the confidence to do that yeah
and you know uh
daniel the smosh ceo
his previous job was working
very closely with robert and so maybe
we'll have an opportunity to meet i'm
sure
be great to shake his hand tell him
thank you um
okay we've got ten more each uh but
first oh this is what are we what are we
promoting right now daniel i can't
remember
yeah okay we still we still want people
to listen to trump yeah yeah yeah
what is talking about his podcast
instead of our podcast i mean what if
they get hooked on
and then they don't they
they they don't have room for two that'd
be fine
that is fine yeah i mean you might like
trevor better than us yeah and if you do
ain't there ain't nothing wrong with
that that's a good thing trevor talks
too much check it out it's also on
youtube so you can uh
listen to it with your eyes trevor talks
too much
we need to pick up our pages yeah yeah
i'm going to move through a couple i'm
going to i'm going to i'm going to move
through this one pretty fast
number 10
dolly parton
my number 10 is dolly party
and we only did this because of jenna
and jenna's in there no we didn't but
she might be your number one i don't
know is she gonna be on your list jenna
she's jenna's number one
um
yeah and
the
the numbers are arbitrary so we're we're
neck and neck yeah go ahead and okay so
i don't consider myself a long-time
dolly parton uh
fan in terms of you know when i was
listening to merle back in the day even
when i heard that he had written some
songs about her like always wanting you
is supposedly written about her
always wanting you but never having you
yeah uh he had a big crush on him i
always was when i would hear a dolly
parton song i would be like oh that's a
girl that's a great song and i was
obviously attracted to her uh but
it wasn't actually until
dolly parton's america
uh the the podcast was that a radio lab
production is that there was um
that was probably last year or the year
before and it was just an incredible
podcast and i began to really understand
how much of her story identified with
now i don't come from the mountains of
tennessee
but i come from the plains of north
carolina and the planes the idea of
being someone who
because of where you're from there's not
a lot expected of you and you kind of
feel like every time you come into a
room you are bringing that expectation
with you now she exemplifies that in a
huge way because people
thought that oh this is this little
country bumpkin and she was like no no
i'm not just some country bumpkin i'm an
incredible musician i'm an incredible
songwriter and i'm an incredible
businesswoman and i'm going to have an
amusement park and i'm going to have
this place where you can eat while
people are on horseback you know like
and yeah and not just that
but she is an incredible humanitarian
who has found a way to
be very vocal about
marginalized people and very inclusive
as a as
a personal brand without alienating
which is very difficult to do she's
alienated a number of people on the
right at this point just because she's
standing up for marginalized people but
uh she's found a way to maintain a very
broad
audience
in a way that is
people in what can be a very is super
divisive right now right yeah and you
know
we seek to do that i mean to sum it up
it's
a brand ethos built around her true self
you know so it's i think that's
that's how i summarize
the creative inspiration
number nine for me
um
is
i justine
oh well yeah
um
[Music]
you know i have a creator on my list
that's not i justine okay we're of
course we're friends of justine we're
not in constant contact but um you know
we'll go a long time without talking but
she was probably sponsored by constant
contact at some point yes and so were we
you know we we came up together
uh
on the internet but she was ahead of us
yep and i think she was tremendously
influential in that she embraced
cutting-edge technology to set herself
apart
and we noticed that
you know it was
when this website justin tv started
making it possible for you to live
stream yeah she was one of the first
people to say i'm going to live stream
my life
24 7.
i don't know how long she did it but it
was i mean it might it was at least a
year uh it was at least weeks
somewhere between weeks and years i
don't remember that part but i remember
watching
her go about her life
as a student of
what what we were coining the phrase as
entertainment so okay can this
can is this even possible is this a good
idea
we didn't know the answer we found it
out by watching her she didn't know the
answer she found out by doing it yeah
and it
she she set herself apart she got that
edge by being on the cutting edge and it
was something that
that we adopted as a uh as a strategy
and
i think that
directly led to
us doing the rhett and link cast live so
pretty definitely every you know we we
we partnered with you stream she was
also on ustream
and
we did a live internet broadcast every
thursday night from our basement studio
in lillington which is the precursor to
gmm yeah that is what became good
mythical morning we talk a lot about
good morning chia lincoln as being the
precursor to good mythical morning but
two guys at one desk and one microphone
that was right lincast absolutely that's
where it started it was a genre and it
was for us it was live for an hour for
an entire year
and those archives live exclusively on
the weekly society
weekly if you want to see them yeah
they're on the methods and we and we uh
that's where we compare notes too we
developed our
our chops
yeah of
the conversation
that are reflected in what we're doing
right now what we do on good monthly
good morning behind the desk right every
every every day and we and we didn't
have a lot of people to to compare notes
with at the time right and she was one
of the the few that was
you know that we reached out to and
talked to and learned a lot from i've
got a crater on my list
uh as well for similar reasons a little
higher up okay uh number nine for me
jordan peele
yes um
so it's interesting
jordan is a huge influence
on two levels
yeah the first is just very simply
before he was the jordan peel that you
know when he was just the jordan peel of
key and peel right which you also knew
yeah and you know
you know it's arguably just as visible
so
there's i think there's three aspects
that i'll quickly cover the first is the
fact that just you know as a sketch
comedian somebody making sketch that was
connecting on the internet in a huge way
both key and peel
huge inspirations for us we could only
hope to get to be a fraction as funny as
they are in their sketches
and even getting to a fraction of that
would be an accomplishment
the second thing of course
is
what he has accomplished as a filmmaker
which is just bringing comedy and horror
together
horror comedy and social commentary
together in a way that's not cheesy at
all
no one is doing it people are trying to
emulate it no one has emulated it yet
and when he first did it it was i mean
it was just it it was it floored you
yeah because it was so good right out of
the gate and it was like this is
this guy's been sitting on this the
whole time yeah which is the third thing
and
for me the most significant thing
is the transition from
yeah a sketch comedian to a powerhouse
filmmaker
you know and producer b you know in
being in this town for the past 11 going
on 12 years
by the time this comes out i think we'll
have been in la for 12 years
and it'll be our 12th anniversary here
being here for 12 years
and being someone who is primarily
recognized as a youtube person a
youtuber a youtube sensation
you bring that into every room you bring
that into every meeting and it's not a
good it's it's not a plus let's just
it's not a plus in this town to be a
youtube sensation right you come in with
a bunch of baggage that then you have to
unpack and explain explain who you
aren't and what you are capable of
creatively and listen we've been able to
do so many awesome things and i'm very
creatively fulfilled but a lot of the
things that i i
really want us to be able to do
the fact that we have a youtube presence
is actually it works for you and getting
you in the room but works against you
once you're in the room i think the fact
that it's true of entertainers in
general they put you in boxes you put
you in a box no matter what that box is
it's really hard to get out of it and
the fact that he
got out of that box in such a decisive
and such an awesome
way yeah
i look again i
yeah that's not i mean that's not gonna
happen with us okay i'm just gonna be
i'll just go ahead and break the news in
case you want to believe that it's we're
not going to just suddenly make a movie
that is going to blow the world away and
win a bunch of oscars
i mean i could ho i would hope and
that's what we aspire to but chances are
that's not going to happen but just
being able to make that transition in
the way that he did
is so inspirational almost
intimidatingly inspirational
all right
i could have put him on my list i'm
number eight i'm gonna go back
i think i'm gonna steal your thunder
here because i'm gonna stay in the world
of entertainment
and i'm gonna say um the vlog brothers
john and hank green my number eight uh
hold on is this your number eight it's
my number eight okay my number eight is
hank and john as well
so there we go but no you go first
i just talked um
you know they're they're friends of us
they know of ours they know how much
we respect them and it's flattering that
they also respect us we
again with no one to go ahead
of any of us it's
you cling to the people who are holding
on for dear life and trying
to
just
to build an outpost on the frontier of
of what's becoming the future of
entertainment
and for them
to
have
a
a similar relationship
as brothers
uh
you know we watched them closely before
we knew them
uh they weren't in the same room
together usually
yeah but
um they had a connection that was on
display that then they very
overtly
fostered into a community
of they they they named their fans the
nerdfighters they developed an identity
that was bigger than the two of them
what that they participated in
uh like a
like a technical
digital
community of of uh
forums and interactions
uh through through a tool called ning at
the time we're like we're just going to
do what they did
we're going to do we're going to create
a ning community
we're going to name our fans we're going
to let them we're going to empower them
to name themselves but we're going to
suggest mythical beasts right and then
we're going to choose that one together
yeah so
um
the mythical beast's
name moniker was a direct emulation of
their nerdfighteria which then that
becomes the name of our company and so
the branding shifting beyond the two of
us is something that we got from
from them and also
uh how entrepreneurial they are yeah and
it's like starting vidcon and like there
was no
endeavor
that
and you know and then
john
and now hank having this sort of talent
wrapped up in being able to write that
they're kind of you know sitting on as
well
and then unleashing that in the world in
a really significant way
that isn't they're being recognized for
their accomplishments not because they
had a youtube channel but because
they're genuinely talented at writing
you know and again that's just that's
that's
that's inspirational to me as well
number seven
i feel bad not i feel bad putting this
man
on the list in a place that isn't of
preeminence but
merle haggard is my number seven now i'm
my number seven is merle haggard oh
really
yeah i guess we're thinking the same
crazy how this ended up happening and
and you know there's okay i'll let you
couch this one because there's different
you know this is a tough one well i'll
just be honest with you there was a
point in which merle was not on the list
because when i was thinking about him
was like
we're not country music i love his i
absolutely love his music
but from his creative influence
uh what kind of creative influences he
had is that how i think about merle or i
was thinking about this guy that just i
love the way he does what he does but
then i started realizing
oh no like
i've sung
we talked about it we were recently on a
ski trip together with our boys
we were coming back down we were
actually as we were going up there i
think no coming back down we listened to
merle a playlist that you put together
yeah which i asked you to share with me
and you still haven't shared with me by
the way yeah i wanted you to ask me
again but it's basically
the best mural throughout the years
which we pretty much agree exactly on
what that is
and i just don't i'm not a guy who makes
playlists and so i need you to make them
for me so i can enjoy them but in
listening to that playlist
one of the things you said was you know
this stuff is just so we listened to
this so much because we grew up in a
different era we grew up in a time when
you had tapes and it was the tapes that
you had that you played and so it was
like it was like
building
10 spotify playlists and never departing
from them for like a 10-year period if
you were to do that right think about a
way that music and the person behind
that music would seep into your bones
you couldn't even shuffle it
yeah right and so
the way first of all the way that we
sing
is heavily influenced by the way
we think about melody right it's heavily
influenced by merle haggard
uh and so that and music is a big part
of what we do
and ha and has been
even a bigger part of what we do
uh in the past so
it isn't that there's something that
merle has done this is more of the
indirect influence sort of thing that
like you're around somebody and it seeps
into you and you know that it's
influencing the way you go about things
i think i can make it a little more
direct i think that
we would
pick songs of his
and we would dissect them i think there
was
like an art appreciation aspect to we
would sit in the car we would pick it
apart and appreciate parts of it so
we never had
like art appreciation classes to really
understand the value
of of how art can move you it just
wasn't an emphasis
of ours in high school but it was
something that we found ourselves doing
impromptu through his music
and we would marvel
at the subject matters that he would
choose to
[Music]
the pictures he would paint
and how we would say things like there's
nobody else writing songs like this on
the radio it there was a there was an
innovation in our minds there was a
it was it was
unique um and the choices that he was
making the thing we talk about a lot is
it was self-expression well in the way
is it different in the way that he
brought like when he gets into the late
70s early 80s which is our favorite era
uh just and i'm also i'm beginning to
say era instead of era just okay if you
sound uh i guess just because era sounds
like you might be saying era error era
okay
you know all right i think it's like the
official new york times uh pronunciation
i don't know how did merle say it you
real no no he didn't um so
the thing that he was doing at the time
is the choices he was making musically
with instrumentation the fact that he
was like bringing in this jazz influence
out of nowhere and all of a sudden there
was a saxophone in country music and no
one was doing that kind of thing
it wasn't like
when you listen to
music and you're just like i just like
the way this makes me feel and this is
just a cool vibe
it was that but then it was just like oh
man this was a
an exercise in curation when he was
making these making these songs the way
that he
brought these specific people together
to make this specific sound and you just
just the other day when we were
listening to that playlist i was just
reminded i'm like
no one no one has done this the
singularity of the voice and how we
could we could study its development
helped us understand
the identity of an artist yeah you know
what i i want to take an aside in um
on the ski trip coming back you know i
made that playlist like months earlier
and i was just laying in my bed and i
was like i'm going to take all of
my favorite merle haggard songs and i'm
going to make a playlist
and so
you know without we know all of his
discography so well that like without
even listening to them i could go album
by album and just pick the songs that
like
are just magical that's what i called
the playlist
that sounds like something we would
written on a cassette exactly in 10th
grade and you know what i never
listened to the playlist
and then when we went skiing you never
listened to that playlist i never went
back and listened to it
um and it's probably been
nine months since i made it and so when
we were coming back down we
skiing with the boys and then we were
driving back
that afternoon i was i got in the car
and i was i thought of the playlist and
i was like this will be perfect i'm
going to start playing this thing and i
didn't tell you any of this but i you
know i started playing
the i said i made this playlist this
moral playlist
and that's all i said and i started
playing it
and
uh you know we drove all the way down
the mountain absolutely beautiful
sunset on coming from big bear on what's
in the rim of the world road you you ha
you actually for those of you in
california you don't come down to 330 to
san bernardino you stay on the mountain
and go past lake arrowhead and stay it's
called the rim of the world and if the
the sun is crazy it's amazing it's like
once
it sets you can see like all of los
angeles
and then when the lights end you know
that's that's the coastline
uh
and it was so beautiful and it to me it
was the the boys were on their
phones or falling asleep in the back
exhausted from skiing and
it was
it was a flashback to when we were in
high school and we would just sit there
in the car drive around aimlessly and
listen to these mural mixtapes that we
would make for each other and it was
it was a
it was a pristine moment
and you know it's at a certain point we
get down the mountain you fell asleep a
little bit you wake back up the playlist
is still going we're like we're not
really talking that much but when we
were we were usually talking about the
music which is what we would do
and it had been i mean it had been
so long since we had done that it was
like i just remember thinking
this is perfect this is so this is a
special friendship moment
and
we got back to my house where you had
parked and we were going to part ways
and it was basically the end of the
playlist like when it got back to like
the
60s yeah well it was yeah when i was
stuff that i wasn't as interested in so
the playlist came to an end basically it
was perfectly time for this trip i
didn't even know it and at the one point
where like you woke up and it was still
going and we were talking about it and
you said
you know send me this playlist
but you didn't i got to tell you
i realized at that moment that
that is my love language
making playlists no use somebody's
saying unprompted hey what is what is
this
and it's happened a couple other times
like what is it what's this music that
you're playing here i said oh it's a
playlist i made hey and then a few days
later get a text hey can you send me
that playlist you made
that is my love language you're a dj so
yeah i'm a dj i mean like really you
miss your calling you shouldn't be a
hair stylist you should be a dj but the
but the tie to
the fact that like without either one of
us talking about what i'm saying right
now
it like that was to me that was your way
of saying hey this
this resonated with me this this means
something to me too this took me back
send me that playlist yeah cause that
because because the mural
discography is so big i just find myself
there's like a couple of albums that
i'll bring up on spotify and every
single playlist that people have made on
spotify sucks because they always put
okie from muskogee as like the first
song there's two reasons
people don't understand merle haggard
like 99 of people who like him don't
understand him it's my contention the
yeah so it's but we do
and that's something it's something
special that we've had yeah and that we
relived in that moment so hey it was it
was it was a very special it was very
special but it would be even more
special if you would just send me the
playlist the reason why i didn't send it
is because
i'm
i'm
thinking about tweaking the order
but the other reason is well you can
tweet the order and just keep sharing it
with me it'll
update automatically i wanted you to ask
me again because it made me feel so good
when you asked me i was like that's a
little selfish yeah it was that's a
little selfish all right i'll send it to
you and you know what i will also share
it with you i will tweet it out
uh so
go to my twitter it'll lead you to my
spotify
i'll tweet it out and then if it changes
over time it's because i'm i'm adding
i'm optimizing it yeah magical mural
number six
right
what's your number six
uh number six is flight of the concords
oh
i didn't think about them
really
yes okay this is great glad you did okay
so
if you're not familiar with flight of
the concords i'm sorry
uh but this is
brett and jermaine
jermaine clement who
lots of people call him germain clement
but it's gemma inclement which i guess
is a kiwi name
um
yeah so these are new zealanders
that are kind of in the you know
germaine has gone on to become an actor
that you would recognize from
many different movies you might
recognize brett from lord of the rings
fellowship by the ring as an elf but
just as a very brief i mean he won an
oscar for writing the music for the the
muppet the muppet movie yeah so he's
kind of gone into the songwriting thing
and i think jermaine is is is more doing
the acting thing and producing
creator of what we do in the shadow so
jermaine was in what we do in the
shadows and so he's collaborating with
taika watiti who didn't make my list but
it's an honorable mention oh yes uh i
love taika but he's more of a recent
influence and i only know about him
through germaine so and that comedic
tone that kiwi tone
it just blew us away he just is like
nectar into my mouth but obviously you
love it yeah so what we do in the
shadows is probably my favorite
television show comedy yeah
uh currently right um but the but the
specific thing so flight of the
concourse is the two-man band
uh that brett and jermaine formed
probably right around the time that we
were coming up and trying to get our
comedy going i specifically remember
i specifically remember myspace
well no i remember being on
a trip oh a campus crusade for christ
trip that we were going on like probably
2002 2003 where we're traveling around
doing our little comedy show that's
really just an evangelism training
seminar for christian students but we
have funny songs we had a lot of fun
songs weren't nearly as funny as these
two well we're in a i remember being in
a hotel room yes i remember this turning
on hbo
and all of a sudden there's these two
dudes
singing it's a stand-up special but it's
two guys on a stage and they're singing
business time is probably the first one
which is a song about having married sex
and it's incredible
and i was just married immediately
i oh gosh these guys are so much funnier
than us like i was shot in the gut yeah
i this has happened so many times in my
life where i'm i feel like i'm doing
something and then i see somebody who's
actually doing what i think i'm doing
and then i see it happening i'm like
damn it i'm not doing it i'm not
actually that good at this yes when we
did we
we looked at each other and
almost thought we had to turn it off we
didn't turn it off we watched the whole
thing
and then i hated them i loved we just
couldn't talk we couldn't talk about it
because they were so good but it was so
it was so it wasn't inspiring it was
challenging it was infuriating it was uh
sobering yeah and i would say that every
effort that we've made in musical comedy
over the years has been
an effort to emulate them on some level
without completely biting what they're
doing
what they did
oh yeah every line
has a comedic effect there's no filler
and it's they each have a character
and
so that we were students of what they
did and this was all before the hbo
series came out that was an adaptation
of their first album yeah uh which had
like a music video it's the reason the
influence buddy system it's the reason
that buddy system has a music video in
every single episode but
i you know the thing i'll say we
actually went in
we
calculated our comedy songs
like as we were developing an audience
on
visuals
that and we we specifically talked about
how not to be compared to them by doing
things differently
so we wouldn't just seem like a hack
ripoff basically just avoiding like
guitar funky
white boy music kind of thing
you know
or uh
kiwi accents yeah yeah
i would have i would i have a recurring
dream of meeting one or both of them
over the years and it's like it's
it's an anxiety dream oh yeah
because you know they don't know who we
are
but it but
the thing is is that um
i uh you know when i listen to our music
and again we don't do a lot of comedy
music anymore it's like
we only have there's only two of us
but and they don't do it anymore really
i mean they're doing it individually but
when i listen to our music anything that
we've created i always find fault with
it and this is any artist i guess but
like i listen to i listen to our music
and i'm like yeah okay well i'd love to
rewrite that right now i'd love to make
that actually funny right
but and i always you know in my mind i'm
never not comparing it to what they did
the the moment of discovery
of that special with like no point of
reference at all
yeah we turned it on
hbo two guys sitting on stools playing
music doing the exact same thing we were
doing
i was like whoa whoa whoa what what's
happening here it was really surreal
yeah
um
my number six
is david letterman
so what number did you put david
letterman because i know you put
letterman on your list number one
oh i stole your number one i knew you
were i i knew this was gonna happen i
knew you were he would be on your list
and i knew that he wouldn't be number
one
um
all right say what you will i do i think
he's more of an i think you watched more
letterman than me
and you stayed up later than i did
well i still do
and you watch so you watch more
letterman okay so again this was a
struggle because david letterman is not
an artist in the in the strict sense
right
he's a
he's a late night show
host
uh but this for me is kind of embracing
i don't know i i disagree with what you
just said but go ahead well no no i'm
saying that you i i do believe that it's
an art but what i'm saying is that it's
not a traditional artist category it's
not a musician it's not a filmmaker it's
not a tv show runner it's not a writer
it's a guy it's a it's a personality
but
the reason that he's he's my number one
is because in the same way that my dad
sort of serves as this foundational
uh
influence as the the things that i find
funny and the way that i end up being
funny naturally yeah is very influenced
by the disposition of a guy like david
letterman i've actually come off of that
quite a bit in the past probably five or
six years
just as people's taste in comedy has
changed so the dry
he was he had a dry delivery and it was
kind of
a knowing slyness to it well and most
people if you're if you're younger and
your only experience with letterman is
the cbs days and specifically like the
last three to four years he's just
you would just be like this is a angry
guy this is a guy who's not happy who's
kind of mean doesn't seem to like anyone
doesn't seem to like himself
yeah
i think that's how the younger
generation responds to and if you look
at some of this the way that i kind of
behaved in some of our earlier content
you might come to the same conclusion it
was a calculated thing i was like this
is the role that i'm playing
and as i realize that a lot of people
who enjoy internet content are not into
that they don't want to see somebody you
know they don't like meanness
and they don't even really like slyness
as much so i've i'm i'm a lot more
jovial of a guy in terms of my comedy at
this point but if you go back to his
earlier stuff
well he was kind of like that he he was
that way but the the the reason he's my
number one smiley er and he was he was
silly too
super silly strange
silly and dry yeah well the reason he's
my number one is because
for better or worse
the thing that we are
and i am most known for is being one of
the two hosts a good mythical morning
like again at the end of my life the
thing that will have had the most impact
in the entertainment world will be all
these episodes of good mythical morning
that i've made
and
we
i approach the way that we think about
that show and the way that we embrace
both
some kind of structure that is
presentational that feels kind of
traditional that feels like a television
show
in a way that a lot of youtube content
doesn't feel yeah
that's a huge part of good mythical
morning's consistency reliability and
sort of point of view but the other
piece of it is
this
unhinged
completely um
silly just silliness just a a embrace of
silliness to the point
that
it gets weird he didn't he did a segment
called will it float and it was just
taking an object yeah he did putting it
in water and then
describing if it was floating or not
yeah and he incorporated his mom into
his content the reason that we have our
parents on in our content in that way he
would call his he would call his mom and
talk to her on the phone yeah he he he
had
um
he did these if you go back and look at
the bits now there's a really good book
about this
yeah
can you google the
letterman biography because we read it
we got stevie to read it it was like we
could
i mean it reminded us
stuff stuff we i'd actually never seen
but like the ethos of good mythical
morning is much more like
the early
uh and successful
letterman late show than it is wayne's
world i will say that
not on our list
oh yeah yeah um
and and
you kind of fell in more of that
letterman thing just tell us when you
got the but
for me
i did
you know i i think of you as more of a
letterman type and then i kind of like
my comedic sensibility i don't know
i don't know who that is i think i can
see more of letterman and your dad and
you
i actually have a hard time seeing and i
don't have anybody on my list that's
like that version for me
don't say paul shaffer don't say
that was a joke i knew you wouldn't say
that don't say don knotts
i mean i do think that
i do think that like dana carvey
is is a is a type not just because you
look like him
but i think there is a
uh
is that it yeah let him in the last
guard of the last giant last giant the
last giant of late night yeah and if i
recall this book is also pretty uh
honest you know he's a he's a complex
character he did a lot of things that he
regrets
that obviously i do not endorse
everything that he did as a person or
even everything that he did comedically
but i watched so much letterman with ben
greenwood growing up ben greenwood and
ben greenwood
again i guess in some senses ben should
be on the list because yeah ben was the
one that was really into late night tv i
nev my dad was not into late night tv my
dad was not into that kind of comedy
yeah he also didn't stay up that late
but ben would be like we're going to
watch johnny carson and oh and he's like
oh and when we really want something
really silly we're going to watch
letterman and we watch letterman on nbc
you know the dude was sitting there with
his curly hair the late late show or
whatever it was called tennis shoes and
you would just do so watching an adult
do so such
stupid stuff it's really this really
made us super hard the parallels yeah
from the book he was a weather man and
he like had this
and and then he moved into being a
comedian
and he took a circuitous path to
entertainment just like we did uh he had
an interesting relationship
well he had a
a relationship with his producer like
they were together
for years
um and she's very instrumental in the
book too so it's like that's an
interesting thing that there's like a
there's like a stevie as producer kind
of thing but not as a relationship not
as a relationship
but like there were entire episodes
where she would trick
him like it would be a joke on letterman
like he wouldn't he would get mad yeah
he would get mad but it would it would
be live
live to tape so yeah there's a lot of
stories there that were like we related
to and that make that very formative
so i don't know if i accepted dana
carvey i know i look like him and
there's like a there's a tone but he's a
character actor
i think i'm just talking about the uh
he never played himself you're not gonna
like the i'm not the word zany right you
don't like the word zany but if you're
like okay
this guy or this guy who's the zanier
one well it's like you know what i'm
saying people are gonna pick you if
there's a there's the dry and then
there's the if the opposite's wet it's
like okay i'm the wet guy you're the dry
guy
yeah
yeah and it's
um yeah but i don't know exactly it's
i'm i'm curious you know you can uh
hashtag your biscuits let us both know
who uh who else
i think if you're a student i think
there's a big beyond just who i look
like there's a distinction and who rhett
reminds me again this is a style this is
an oversimplification but the thing that
we say quite a bit
is that
i'm usually
funny on purpose and you're usually
funny on accident now that's that's an
oversimplification because a lot of your
accidental humor
is purposeful it's a different mode
you don't know what's going to come out
of your mouth
you don't know exactly what's going to
happen but you go into a sort of like a
trance-like state i mean good mythical
evening obviously is the probably the
perfect example of this
but it's like it wasn't a trance but
yeah it's it's more it's more chaotic
yeah you know it's it's it's chaotic and
which is great maybe there's i and that
makes me think of a martin short but i
didn't watch a lot of martin short you
know
so i don't so it's not
i'm not actively emulating somebody and
i can't identify actually that's really
good because if you watch uh only
murders in the building which i did and
i enjoyed it it's not my favorite but i
enjoyed it
i am the steve martin you are the martin
short right all day long
without a doubt you know right if you
have to put us into that duo that's how
it tracks i think that works you know
yeah i think that works
uh but we're still open to others
hashtag your biscuits
um
sorry to sell your number one
yeah that hurts just like that playlist
my number
so now we need your number six no you're
number five my number five you already
stole that as well ross mcelwee okay my
number five
is
seinfeld
that's my number two oh god
okay
um
yeah and you know i'll just i'm really
interested what your top three are gonna
be now my
for seinfeld i just boiled it down to
like the relatable
observational humor is something that
became a cornerstone of
how anything we write what we would
build
to connect on youtube but it was
instinctual because we were so obsessed
with that show i actually put
seinfeld slash larry david as one yeah
yeah right yeah you got to so because
larry david was the one that was really
fueling the writing of all that stuff
yeah you know i mean obviously seinfeld
was very much it was coming from his
stand up which was super observational
what's the deal with this
but bringing it into the real world and
into a real conversation larry david is
a genius at that and obviously he does
it it's on display and curb your
enthusiasm which i love as well
it's it's
i think the thing that he's the george
costanza character in seinfeld though
the thing that it so resonates with me
as a writer
right and that's why i i put them at
number two because if i start thinking
about a okay you got these two people in
this scene and we need to accomplish
this plot-wise but they need to get
there in an entertaining way so they
need to be having a conversation about
this
well right the way that larry david sees
conversational humor
is it's it's the same thing that it
comes from this tendency that's in both
of us which is
hey
we just hung out with you you were just
talking about it on the last podcast we
just hung out with this guy let's talk
about that
let's pick him let's talk about the hat
he had on right look did you did you see
what he was doing did you see what he
was doing with his left hand and his
nose yes explain that to me right and
it's
nothing in seinfeld there were no jokes
it was not joke oriented it was
conceptual right conversational yeah and
so it very much is
is how we like to write and it gets very
specific
and it gets it's like oh you typically
wouldn't think that we should be having
a conversation about this or this is
where the humor should be coming from
it feels like
i don't even know how to articulate it
very well but
when i watch and the only way i really
watch curb your enthusiasm these days is
like
on tick tock i hate to say it you know i
gotta i gotta get a clip a clip will
just come up whether it's on the curb
your enthusiasm actual account or just
somebody has reposted it and i'm just
like this moment where something happens
and i'm just like ah man this is like
that's so great so that's your number
two yeah you've taken my one am i two
was what's your four
cohen brothers
that what we were just talking about
made me realize that they weren't on my
list but yeah
that cohen brothers are not on your list
i just forgot
i just forgot but yeah it's that same
thing it's it's a different there's
it's character-driven comedy which we've
talked about before is another big part
of like what finding ourselves
really loving their comedy and then
trying to figure out why and having
conversations about it there's so many
so much about the cohen brothers i can
say
one their partnership right
which is obviously very relatable to us
um
they
there's a creative evolution over the
course of their career of them like
trying something and you see these like
glimmers of it and like blood simple in
which we would we would like we kind of
went into our like coen brothers like
film study kind of our version of that
like let's go watch blood simple and
make ourselves like it right yeah you
know
and then
which and then you get what i think is
the just for me
maybe for you is just the quintessential
perfect expression of them as filmmakers
as oh brother
you know
that's where it gets into this thing
that is
the humor
the music
yeah the characters every everything
just lines up in a way that they're and
they basically just hit it out of the
park every time now as far as i'm
concerned i mean there's a couple couple
times where i'm not quite as into the
subject matter i don't quite relate as
much but we yeah we this is we talked
about this on the you know our top 10
films it's kind of
there's that overlap there but they're
it's just an asp
they're so
aspirational
because they do what they do what they
do so well and i think again
underneath everything that we've
accomplished has always been
this desire to make movies
you know
yeah and and i still want to do it and
yes we have written one
you know um
and i just don't think i'm ever going to
let go of that desire to be a filmmaker
not instead of or in place of what we do
but in addition to what we do because
there's just something about
the way that you can bring all this
creative energy into a
time and place
over the course of a couple of hours
and you can
get it done in a year or whatever you
know from start to finish
there's just something so attractive
about that process and when i think
about how that's ultimately sort of the
the white whale for me personally of
like that that's that's what i'm always
chasing is i want to make that movie
they are the embodiment of it having
been done perfectly
um
my number four
wouldn't have been on my list except
that like in a recent conversation i was
i was reminded of them
um
john boy and billy big show oh wow okay
i thought about them for a second and
yeah well because i didn't put them you
know like in high school
we were we were listening to their
morning show still going to this day
uh
but it was you know they were a duo
that was
they were radio personalities so it was
conversational and you'd be with them
for like if for summer
like on the job with my dad like
painting houses we would listen to it in
the truck we'd listen to it while we
were painting i would listen to the
whole three or three hours every single
weekday
and
you know they come back from commercial
and say all right we're gonna call
so and so and it would be the different
they would have sketches where it was
like they were playing different
characters
but it's like you you had this keen
awareness
well i don't know if i knew it first but
you
eventually i wise that was like they
were playing these two guys are beating
everybody these people aren't calling
and i'd have comedians come in and guess
but they had their own world
with
it was like self-contained yeah that was
and you became a part of it
you know and like you do you got to know
them as people and i think that we have
this understanding of the audience
experience for good myth good morning
and for this show
because because we had that experience
with them
that's why it was so thrilling when they
like i said they invited us
to once we started
making those viral videos
we're gonna be on the show the
commercials we got to be on the show and
i took my dad there and john boyd took
us to it to his uh
ranch his like farm farmhouse and like
we hung out and
i actually stayed the night i actually
got a text from from carl
carl the cook yeah uh he went to my old
guy who made their barbecue sauce yeah
he said i'll send y'all some barbecue
sauce the guy who got drunk and said man
has anybody ever told you you look like
a falcon yeah
you did your face
i couldn't figure out how to get in
touch with him because
uh falcon man the uh
it went to my like google number and
it's like they couldn't see but yeah we
got to get in touch with them
you know i mean more the more you talk
about it the more i really like to work
the sketch work so much of that and it
was audio it was like what we did as
kids we would do we would do radio shows
it really influenced a lot of the
characters that we created in the early
days the redneck character guys you know
we had like all different we had an
array of them yeah and so it was and and
when you talk about just the amount i'll
keep them straight up there actual
exposure to a particu potential
influence right
we just i mean you that's what you did
you turned on jumbo and billy on the way
to high school every single day yeah so
it's like we absorbed their
sensibilities yeah and we got to know
them as real people too so you saw both
sides of it
all right
i think i've wiped you out no i have one
more my number three all right what's
your number three i think i know what i
know someone that's in your top three
that is on my honorable mentions but
i'll let you say uh but my number three
is weird owl
okay
weird al is my number two okay
uh
i mean so you get to talk about him
first i regret when weird al came on
good mythical morning that we didn't
like
worship him i know worship him yeah give
him offerings and like give him some
like a burnt offering the first
cassette tape we both ever owned was
weirdo
and i still have mine
i wish i would have brought it that day
and had him sign it
uh we'll just ha we should have him back
on the show
we should we should that was during gmm
22 where it was so hectic that was like
oh we're down here i don't have time to
process that
he's playing as accordion on the show
yeah but there's also like a woman who
looks like a stripper i don't like what
was a strange episode what was i wasn't
all about him and that was it was a
disservice to the great weird owl
number two creative influence on my list
because
i you know
i got engaged with this comedy music and
it just like made the most sense like i
wasn't even a music fan before that
really yeah like i was
because my step older stepsister liked
music and i wasn't gonna like anything
she liked
until weird out bucks you out of music i
was like she is i mean he is so
this is this just totally makes sense
yeah it was it was it was like it was
tailor-made taylor made for us and it's
strange that like
i knew i i didn't know on every one of
his albums i didn't watch
uh
his movie
so it wasn't like i was a super fan
but at such a formative time
in our lives when we were like really
hitting it off and like making
making those dumb tapes that we were
making
we weren't writing songs together yet
but it was just like
that stuff
it's foundational
you know in terms of in terms of comedy
and obviously starting our career as
musical comedians for the most part and
one and one of the first things
really you know
apart from some of the things that we
did in high school
and then a couple of the videos that we
made in college
the first thing that we did together as
a comedic duo right was comedy music
yeah
uh it was those first couple of
christmas conferences oh no i i i you
tell my i'm talking about like you're
down with halloween like rewriting the
words yeah yeah that's true rewriting
the words and getting up on stage at the
fall off but any time that we were
performing yeah so we did it we did it
there we did it in middle school but
then in college performing at those
campus crusade things it was just like
all right we're going to get up there
and we're going to do we're going to do
this funny song about the unibrow or
whatever right together and it was
our
voices
kind of went into a sort of nasally
weird out place that
kind of nerdy people talk about so a lot
of our early stuff sounds very weird out
e yeah um
and that was you know it was because we
had listened to so much weird out it was
just it was in our bones
um
okay so
that was my number two that was your
so yeah so i've taken my two my you've
already taken my two seinfeld larry
david in one letterman all right so i
gotta clean it up my number three
you have three more i have two more
because weirdos are my number two oh my
number three i put quest love
like i'm a huge fan of quest love
and uh
just he's a huge creative inspiration
that is a within the last
two
years
addition to my list of course he's a
he's a hip-hop icon as a
member and drummer for the roots he's
he's a band leader for fallon which is
the roots
on fallon um but in terms of like meek
you know you talk about me wanting to be
a dj and telling that story like
uh i it's a product of like me
connecting you're like looking at me
like you're like shocked or something no
i'm sure i'm interested to hear this um
because i would not have guessed this uh
just really identifying the
the
like how much i enjoy
music
on like an appreciation level
you know uh of course with our merle
haggard obsession like way back in the
day i remember i went to heather
wilson's house and her dad had a
magazine called it was a country music
uh heritage magazine and it like talked
about
like the best country music albums and i
was like
i remember thinking then i like
i i took the magazine i still have it
so like back in high school it was
something i was very passionate about
country music as an as a offshoot of our
passion for male hacker but you know
like i go to 11 when it comes to like
like the collection mentality and like
uh like the pre-wiki wiki mentality of
understanding
everything about country music and i
started to think i could become a
like a country music museum curator
like maybe that maybe that can be
something i'll do i remember thinking
about that's why i kept that magazine
all these years and still have it
and then it was over the pandemic there
was like a rekindling of that
which led to like the listening party
broadcast that i did with britain and
stuff like that but it was a result
of like me starting to watch quest
love's broadcast on instagram where he
would like do dj sets
and he would start talking about the
music that he was playing and it was
like i mean he is a he's in he has an
encyclopedic knowledge
of all these things he
but it's
he has
i'm not a fan of the roots i've never
listened to the roots
i'm a fan of him in the way he did back
us up while we did our you're down with
halloween yeah we did which is we've
been we've been backed by the roots
before i mean that was that was a that
was a career
and friendship high point for us
but like um the fact that he
branches out into
in middle age
you know he's like five years older than
us
but he's using everything from his
career to now do
to to capitalize and do the things that
he's passionate about so he's writing
books he wrote a book about creativity
yeah called creative quest
which i've i've read some of he
executive produces
a hip-hop documentary on an amc called
uh
the
songs that shook
which is amazing
and now he's nominated for an oscar for
best documentary film for uh summer of
soul which is a uh it's it's like the
uh the black woodstock basically that
was never
the footage was never released
and he's nominated for an oscar for and
he deserves it and it's you know so the
way that he's branching out and engaging
everything that
up
from a career standpoint up to this
point that like he's leveraging
is uh is cool to see
and um so it's it's very encouraging
that like
we talk about the things
we want to do like you were doing
earlier and it's you know i see a guy
like him that's like a he's an elder
statesman and music and he's he hasn't
um
um he doesn't just do one thing he
doesn't just do one thing he does a lot
so so when we think about our legacy and
we think about the things that we have
yet to do
those are two different things but they
they interplay and it's so even if it's
something like us investing in the next
generation of creators with our mythical
creator accelerator
you know it's it's just another example
of hey we're gonna
we're going to we're going to pay it
forward
and but we're still here for it
you know oh yeah we're not retiring
still a lot to do um
so
yeah
and questlove i've met him we met him
once known that you felt that way
about questlove
when he was playing the drums for us
rapping i would have probably been more
nervous
uh
i came to grips with it afterward i
wasn't as oh okay yeah
because it was more pandemic related all
right so i just have my number one
which is for both of us you don't have
you don't have any left
yeah but i mean i gotta
you want to guess who it is
is it wes anderson
no i went in a totally different
direction because i was like he was on
my honorable mention but i was like link
loves was anderson so much as you can
put him number one but i was like but as
your list goes on i'm like that can't be
yeah
okay and this is this is for both of us
you're not going to disagree with this
because again with everything we've
talked about my number one i'm putting
benny and zore
yes baby wow
uh
yeah okay i mean yeah i mean it just
didn't cross my mind but but now that
i've said it it totally makes sense
right oh yeah okay
maybe you've heard his name maybe you
know from the book of mythicality that's
talking about him or all the times we
talked about our high school band
the wax paper dogs ended in a z it was
the 90s
so
matt enzore was in our grade his younger
brother john was one year younger but
their dad
benny
was
he he played the the piano at at the
church that we went to we always knew
him growing up growing up he was one of
the youth leaders
and also a dad he was a soccer coach uh
when
when my mom got divorced and me and
uh her moved into our own places the two
of us it was across the street from the
enzors
which they still live over there um so
it's like in the small community he was
very present
at church at soccer
in the community and then at school
later on
that's right and then he then he worked
he was like the detent the guy who in
charge of the detention
i wish i had to get to the high school i
had to go to detention and the guy in
charge of it
was my keyboard player
yeah so it's like benny started
through the church
he started
a cafe for the uh like a coffee shop for
yeah this is you're you're you're you're
this is true you're you're you're i'm
just
i didn't think about it but now that
you're putting it all together yes
because i know we didn't besides your
dad we didn't think of it in terms of
personal
interpersonal relationships we talked
about in terms of like
external yeah
celebrity influences but yeah he started
the maranatha cafe coffee shop to have
campbell university students could hang
out and and it was a way for the church
to have to create a space a safe space
for them to hang out listen to music
there was an open mic night
which then
we as high school students involved in
the church we helped facilitate move
chairs around we helped
renovate the building and decorate it
and benny was a huge
um
music fan and musician he's a great
pianist also played guitar
and uh huge almond brothers fan
from like and so he he was a hippie
he kind of well he had a hippie vibe he
had longer shaggy hair he didn't look
like any of
any of our other parents
and he would um
he took all of his old records and then
we decorated the maranatha cafe with all
of his records
so it wasn't christian music it was like
70s albums walled a wall that became the
wallpaper it was like super cool yeah
and and it was his baby
and because it was because of because of
the open mic night the fact that the
maranatha cafe existed and there was
this yeah opening my night
open mic night
that was what gave us the courage or the
opportunity we didn't need the courage
the opportunity to be like well of
course we're going to perform at the
open mic night
and that was when
eric woodruff had a guitar
and he could play he could play the
guitar john enzor had a bass he was
learning
he was definitely learning and of course
eric was learning too but he was the
most proficient at the time yeah and i
remember
the first song
we ever wrote
was about uh
decree
ironically given our
specifically my deconstruction story was
about creation it was basically about
how creation proves that god exists
and that it happened in seven days yeah
yeah
but the reason why i made fun of the
organic soup and life you know
spontaneous life but we had to write
christians
we had to write christian songs because
to play the open mic night you didn't
have to play christian music it was a
christian cafe but that's where benny
comes in because benny listened to
our creation song
and was like
uh
boys you know if you're really serious
about playing music
you should probably learn how to play
cover songs like you should learn how to
play other songs that have been written
and he was also like and i've got some
old songs that i wrote like 20 years ago
that you could also play and so that was
the beginning of us because again
most people who sit down even if you
listen to music a lot you sit down to
write a song even if you can play a few
chords
you don't understand song structure you
don't understand like oh there's this
number of measures in the verse and
there's a bridge and there's a chorus
and like there's a structure that it
follows
if you just start writing you have no
idea benny saw that immediately
and then was like here's some songs like
hey can you just look what if you just
played
i can see clearly now the rain is gone
yeah or country roads by john denver and
it was that's how he learned how to sing
and that's how i learned how to play the
guitar because
you know but he also said and i can also
be in the band to help you actually make
this into a like to like keep the beat
yeah i'll play keyboard and like if you
need a beat there'll be a beat on my
keyboard we didn't have a drummer yet
early in the day right and and we
started writing songs we he brought out
yeah like he had all these songs that he
had written in the 70s like handwritten
and he like taught them to us
and we we sang them yeah and it was like
almond brothers meets
john denver sung by two guys who tried
it you're trying to sound like hank
williams jr right it was a train wreck i
think the there's a whole other podcast
just about
wax paper dogs but i just want to say
that like we threw ourselves into this
band and because there was an adult in
the room who
we considered he he it was like he was a
peer
he was he was john matt did our sound
and did all the tech stuff but
we were we were a group of peers and he
didn't elevate himself above us
and we had so much fun we threw
ourselves into it we committed so
wholeheartedly to it and there's
something about being in a band that
really helps you develop creatively we
were making
thousands of creative decisions
in every time we would get together and
so you start to learn to work with for
other people
and you learn how you learn how you
learn to trust yourself creatively and
you learn to put yourself out because
what ended up happening is
within that first year
we went from
an old an older guy
giving us his music and having the drums
be on the keyboard
to
me and you sitting in a room somewhere
writing a song and we started writing
yeah we never had the courage to do that
without him yeah you and i were writing
music for the wax paper dogs together
writing music and lyrics and then the
other thing we were doing is we were
making them a little funny like they all
had to be like
veiled they well some of them were like
overt christian
and some of them were veiled but they
and some of them started to get funny
and that's where we st
the only surviving recording actually
is is funny a little bit funny it's a
racial reconciliation song yeah but it
has a reference to a professional
wrestler
right
so
i mean we can we can get into all this
in more detail later but for now
just just like we did in the book of
mythicality we're like giving throwback
thanks to to benny because i you know in
a lot of ways i don't think we would be
here because as creators
he really fanned that flame and gave us
a sense of identity as creative people
that translated into
what we wore
what the music we listened to by the
time we got to went off to college we
looked we had fully embraced like the
90s alternative thing unlike anybody in
our high school and unlike anybody we
associated with in college so it was a
it wasn't just an artistic thing it was
a and a complete identity it set up our
it set up our personalities in some ways
of
yeah
always feeling like we didn't quite fit
but kind of taking a little bit of pride
in that i think you know to be
transparent about it oh yeah
yeah that's a good one i think benny
will be you know i i texted with john
not too not too long ago so i'll let him
know that benny gets the shout out yeah
um love you benny now
okay
we talked we went ahead and talked ahead
of time about one thing we didn't give
any
heads up on who was going to be on our
list but
the thing that we had a conversation
about was that if this
list was in fact
factual right that we would be each
other's number one right you know
because we can be each other zero so
we'll be each other zero we
obviously the most significant creative
influence that is embodied in a person
in each of our lives is each other
because
we don't do any creativity for the most
part where we're not directly consulting
with one another and it's it's a product
of our collective imagination yeah as i
mean and i'll also give a shout out to
stevie yeah in terms of uh
you know it's like she's she's become a
creative sound board for us that like we
hatch things
and then we always know that there's
like
the next phase is getting stevie's
buy-in and like her applying her filters
to the in first reaction to
the next thing we're hatching yeah
stevia has been and then obviously
shaping creatively
everything you see at mythical
um
that we're involved in or not she's the
first she's the first filter besides
each other yeah for everything we do
yeah i want to i want to shout out jesse
my wife as well i i i tend to discuss i
love that we're using the term shout out
just so we're bringing it back uh i want
to give heartbeat props to my wife yeah
um
because i i very rarely think about
anything creatively
that i don't consult her about i you
know anything that i write i give to her
when i'm done and
you if i get stuck creatively a lot of
times because i do a lot of stuff at
home too i do a lot of writing at home
because i don't have enough time to do
it at work um
so she's been a huge influence and also
you know go back to the fact that both
of our wives were the ones who sort of
encouraged us oh yeah to make a creative
thing our profession back in the day so
oh absolutely um but yeah and i'm saying
so we'll make each other our zero on the
list
which sounds bad but i think it's good
because it's like there's not
any at every single point
i surprised you with the quest love
thing but
basically there's so much overlap it's
like 99.9
creative overlap over so many years
that like we touch so much that even the
things that we that we don't touch
in in the other person's creative
endeavors it it it will
the presence will be well which is why
you'll probably relate to i'm just going
to quickly run through the honorable
mentions the ones that were in the
initial batch but then got pushed off
wes anderson okay
spike jones
quinn tarantino
rob reiner
glover
yeah errol morris as i said the lonely
island yeah
taika watiti
robert rodriguez the duploss brothers
okay
will smith
yeah and werner herzog okay
all right well let's wrap this thing up
this has been a long one um so i guess i
stole your wreck yeah sherman's march
but so let's just make this a double
wreck because we mentioned two things
that are really good uh the first thing
is ross mcelwee's which it looks like
mckelly m-c-e-l-w-e-e
sherman's march
great documentary i'm sure you can get
it on amazon or whatever
and then that letterman book the last
giant of late night i think if you're in
a creative profession and you're just
trying to figure out how to like
define yourself creatively or you've got
a creative endeavor that you're
currently in the middle of i think that
can be a pretty inspirational book
david letterman the last giant of late
night all right it's been a fun one
hopefully you're um
inspired your creative juices are
flowing tell us who your creative
influences are hashtag ear biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]